float on down we're going deep into the
sewers to dig up all the Easter eggs and
references you might have missed in it
chapter 2 now is your last chance to
turn back because there are plenty of
spoilers and scares ahead Stephen King's
stories are often connected through
their New England locations as well as
their monsters it takes place in Derry
Maine and the book often references the
nearby town of Castle Rock where
multiple works by king or sets including
his novella the body and its movie
adaptations stand by me these two
stories are also connected through their
focus on friendship childhood trauma and
the end of innocence as groups of kids
are forced to confront dark forces
around them while supernatural and human
at the end of stand by me Gordie
LaChance is finishing the last lines of
his memoir inspired by the news of his
childhood best friend's death his office
has dark wood paneling and a wall of
books around him as well as a picture
window looking out onto the front yard
in it chapter 2 Bill's office is a
replica of Gordy's albeit with a sleek
laptop rather than a clunky 1980s home
computer and like in standby me bill is
working on his own book about childhood
1986 is stand by me was the film that
gave Stephen King a reputation for more
than his horror stories it also helped
catapult young actors River Phoenix Wil
Wheaton Corey Feldman and Jerry
O'Connell to stardom in film and
television
Phoenix's promising career was sadly cut
short in its prime when he died of an
overdose in 1993 in it chapter 2 the
film adaptation of Bill's horror novel
is being held by Peter Bogdanovich who
directed River Phoenix and one of his
final films the thing called love as it
turns out cinema legend Bogdanovich is
actually a friend of it director and EMU
sketti and asked for the cameo
personally the connection to stand by me
and River Phoenix is the poetry of
coincidence but still brings a
melancholy touch to it chapter 2 for
fans who remember him fondly in Stephen
King's epic gunslinger fantasy series
The Dark Tower roses have a special
significance their appearance often
indicates a nearby portal to parallel
universes and certain roses are powerful
enough to enchant and heal with their
mystical properties one in particular
known simply as the Rose is found in an
abandoned Lots in New York City at the
corner of 2nd and 46th Street
Oh symbolism appears frequently in kings
works including it in it chapter two
bill finds his old bike silver at the
vintage shop secondhand rose which is a
sly reference to things that were once
beautiful and important but are now
merely taking up shelf space in a
small-town store in the book the store
has the full name secondhand Rose
second-hand cloves and Bill buys his
Schwinn for $20 in chapter 2 the
proprietor played by Stephen King
himself charges bill $300 when the older
losers go back to the house on niebolt
streets in chapter 2 a 1950s era Amana
frigid with scene in chapter 1 makes
another appearance inside the fridge
they find Stanley's decapitated head
along with a host of other nastiness in
the novel it's that bridge played
heavily in a number of disturbing scenes
that have never made it to the screen
due to their graphic nature most notably
the bridge in the junkyard is where
Pennywise victim meant school bully
Patrick Hawks deader would trap animals
and wait for them to suffocate to death
it's also the site where Patrick met his
untimely end in a swarm of flying
leeches
in it chapter 2 the civic pride
expressed by the phrase I heart dairy
takes a sinister turn in Chapter 1 the
message can be seen printed on one of
Penny wises red balloons a reference to
a horrific hate crime in the book that
hadn't been put to screen until chapter
2 after winning an I heart dairy cap at
the canal day's carnival Adrian melon
and his boyfriend began walking home
talking about their future on the way
they are set upon by a group of
homophobic bullies who viciously beat
the couple throwing Adrian's body over
the bridge and into the speeding current
below where Pennywise proceeds to eat
him King based Adrian melons storyline
on a real-life hate crime that played
out exactly as he wrote it - the
cannibal clown and Beast it chapter two
is the first adaptation to put these
horrifying events on screen putting the
previous I heart dairy reference into
its proper context in every it
adaptation and as per the book the local
cinema plays a huge part and the loser
story during the summer it's a safe
space for kids to escape from Henry
Bowers and his gang of bullies it's also
the place where many a penny wises
tormenting monsters take shape for the
losers like Richie's Wolfman but in it
chapter 2 the movie theater is boarded
up and closed down with only movie
posters to indicate when the shuttering
happened we get a closer look when
Richie visits the place during his
search for a token and one of the
posters is 1998 Tom Hanks and Meg Ryan
rom-com you've got mail which implies
that the theater closed its doors
sometime before the turn of the century
but more ominously there are two rips in
the poster that spell out a scraggly it
turns out that's a sneaky bit of
foreshadowing since Richie is about to
have his own run-in with penny wise
beep-beep
in the novel the Bradley gang were a
group of gangsters who made dairy a pit
stop during Prohibition
one day in a strange series of events
that points to Pennywise his evil
machinations the Bradley gang were
massacred by town folk and one fell
swoop
the event went down his historic legend
and both in chapter 1 and chapter 2
feature a mural and dairy commemorating
the gruesome event what chapter 2 adds
to the story is that Ben actually found
the Bradley gangs bunker and reinforced
it so the losers could use it as a
hideout from Henry Bowers and the other
bullies this is why Ben finds a bunch of
rusted old padlocks and chains down
there the Bradley gang had already made
this a secure hiding spot and the hole
was waiting in the woods for the losers
to find and adopt as their own check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite horror movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]